what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and what is perhaps the
greatest battle in the seven deadly sins
story is about to begin
as the demon king continues to grow
stronger by the minute and as zelgius is
very existence is now in question Mele
Otis and Elizabeth have been joined by
the sins in order to set up the final
showdown although with the song that Lee
sends manga you never know what is
actually final as we saw in the last
battle against the demon king in this
video I will be breaking down all of the
latest developments in the lead up to
what looks like to be another epic
battle with the highest stakes possible
before we begin this video was sponsored
by crunchyroll
crunchyroll is the world's largest
destination for anime and manga and I've
been a paying customer of crunchyroll
for over three years I use crunchyroll
pretty much every day to watch my
favorite anime series like attack on
Titan JoJo's black clover and many more
this season I am loving doctor stone
which is being simulcast on crunchyroll
along with fire force and other brand
new hit anime series many people don't
realize this but crunchyroll also has a
manga section and that's exactly where I
go to read the latest chapters of the
seven deadly sins manga with the
official translation a ton of you guys
in the past have asked me where to find
the seven deadly sins manga and I just
read it right on crunchyroll go-to
crunchyroll.com slash anime uproar to
get crunchyroll premium free for 14 days
you will get unlimited access to their
anime manga and drama titles ad free in
1080p HD and that includes the newest
anime episodes with professional
subtitles check it out for yourself try
out crunchyroll ad free for 14 days
right now by signing up at
crunchyroll.com slash anime uproar or
just click the link in the description
that way you get the latest anime and
manga content you help support the anime
industry and you help support this
channel at the same time it's a win for
everyone just sign up at crunchyroll.com
slash anime uproar or click that link in
the description and as usual this video
will contain manga spoilers we're gonna
be talking about the latest developments
in the seven deadly sins stories so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned chapter 3 20 starts off with
zelgius consciousness seemingly
completely fading away as the demon king
becomes even
stronger and unlocks yet another epic
form apparently his final form I
mentioned in the last video that even
though Mellie Otis was clearly stronger
than the demon king at the beginning of
this fight the demon king was quickly
and steadily getting stronger and this
has been clearly demonstrated in Chapter
320 in this form the demon king looks
like a character right out of JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure and I have to say that
I am digging this look the demon king
says that thanks to zelgius sacrifice he
has obtained something like his original
body the body from his youth so
apparently this JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
form is actually what the demon king
really looked like back when he was
young when we first met the demon king
in purgatory he already appears to be an
old man with a long beard but if the
demon king is to be believed now this is
what he looked like in his youth it is a
very interesting look to be sure and you
can definitely see the resemblance
between this demon king form and the
adult versions of malleolus and zell
dress that appeared after the demon king
possessed their bodies but more
importantly than just his look I am
wondering whether this means that the
demon king has just become more powerful
than we've ever seen him before since he
was already an old man when we first met
him does that mean that because the
prime of his life was behind him he was
also weaker than he was in his youth and
now that he regained his youth
thanks to sell dresses body he will be
even more powerful than he was in
purgatory and maybe even more powerful
than he was when he possessed
melioidosis body the demon king tells
malleolus to give it up because his
little brother is gone seemingly zelgius
his presence has completely vanished his
consciousness has evaporated and the
demon king is now in complete control of
his vessel but meliodas refuses to
accept it and he says that he knows that
zelgius isn't gone and a furious battle
ensues as Mellie Otis also continues to
power up in order to keep fighting the
demon king so his meliodas right when he
says that despite the fact that they can
no longer send Zelda's presence he is
still in there somewhere
or is zell just really gone and the
demon king is now in full control
personally i totally agree with melio
Tissier sure he is zell dresses brother
and he would want to believe that all is
not lost even if it was but knowing how
the story of the seven deadly sins has
unfolded and knowing all the twists and
tricks that knock us
Sukie has put us through I am certain
that zelgius will come back somehow
after all we summon the autos release
gelda from her seal and she proclaimed
that she was going to find zelgius I am
sure that that part of the story wasn't
included for no reason and that gelda
will pop up once again and what could
possibly be her role if not to help
bring zelgius back from the edge of the
abyss at this point Mele Otis is still
determined to defeat the demon King on
his own without depending on anyone else
and without putting anyone else in
danger but clearly now the situation has
changed the demon king is far more
confident than he was just moments
earlier and the demon king seems
convinced that meliodas cannot defeat
him on his own even Elizabeth tells
meliodas to pull back so that they can
come up with a plan and this tells me
that Elizabeth can sense that the demon
king has undergone a major
transformation and that things are no
longer looking as good for meliodas as
they were just moments ago as meliodas
launches a massive attack against the
demon king the demon king seemingly
absorbs all the magic from the attack
which implies that he is now able to use
his ability called the ruler once again
the demon king does not seem concerned
in the least about melioidosis attacks
and he sees melioidosis tenacity as
nothing more than a great opportunity to
test out his full power it isn't looking
too good formally Otis in this moment he
is clearly emotional and desperate to
save his brother but the demon king is
getting stronger by the minute and Mele
Otis doesn't seem to have a way to
defeat him especially since we know that
he can't outright kill him because that
would also destroy Zell drous but in
that moment something flies at the demon
king at tremendous speed and it turns
out that it is not other than the seven
deadly sins of themselves that is to say
all of the sins except for esken or
having slain the Lovecraftian indira the
sins are here to help malleolus and
Elizabeth finally defeat the demon king
we know that meliodas wanted to keep the
others out of this he didn't want anyone
else to have to suffer because of the
demon king and he didn't want anyone
else to put themselves in danger because
of the actions of his father but in the
end the sins were always going to refuse
to sit this one out as dangerous as this
showdown against the demon king will be
especially now that he has apparently
regained his original body in all of his
original power the sins are still
prepared to risk their lives to help
their friend
and their captain Mellie Otis after all
as bond says rule seven of the seven
deadly sins is that they make sure to
come together and work as a team every
now and then this reunion was definitely
a heartfelt moment and it sets up
another epic showdown between the demon
king who may now be stronger than we've
ever seen him and the seven deadly sins
and Elizabeth but now the big question
is how will this battle unfold has the
demon king already reached his full
power or is he going to continue to get
even stronger and stronger until he is
practically unstoppable also we know
from way back in purgatory that bond has
the ability to counter the ruler the
demon Kings LP technique by giving some
of his own energy to the demon king
instead of trying to hurt the demon king
bond can inflict serious damage on him
if he is using the ruler because the
rulers ability is to reverse attack so
that an attack will actually make him
stronger instead of weakening him but
this also works in the opposite
direction on a tag that is supposed to
make him stronger by giving him some of
bonds energy will be reversed and it
will damage the demon king instead I
mentioned in the previous video that
without bond there during the fight the
demon king was free to use the ruler as
much as he wanted against meliodas and
Elizabeth but as it turns out bond is
now here on the main battlefield and
this will definitely complicate the
demon Kings ability to use the ruler
effectively with the demon king
Elizabeth meliodas and the rest of the
sins with the exception of esken are all
now here in one place the battle is
about to get much more complex and
multifaceted the seven deadly sins can
now use combo moves and the demon king
will have to worry about every single
one of them not just one or two
opponents what's more since we know that
esken aura has now regained the power of
sunshine we can expect him to make his
entrance at some point in the near
future as well with noone around the
corner we are most likely going to see
esken or in the one mode once again this
time helping the sins take on the
strongest version of the demon king i
see this battle as potentially being the
most epic battle yet and I imagine that
the sins and Elizabeth will ultimately
defeat the demon king by using effective
teamwork and combining all of their
unique skills powers and abilities to
outthink and outmaneuver the demon king
with that said
we can't forget about other factors that
may end up playing an important role in
this battle if you've been following the
channel then you know that I've talked
to quite a few times about King Arthur
and the fact that the mother of chaos
aka Hawkes mama foreshadowed that the
King will be reborn if we can take this
seriously and not just as a throwaway
line and if it was a throwaway line then
I don't know why I bother including it
at all then we can expect that Arthur
will somehow be revived and that he will
play some sort of role in the final
battle what exact role is he going to
play I am honestly not sure but I
imagine it will be related to the
legendary sword Excalibur after all this
battle is currently taking place around
the same lake in which the Lady of the
lake resides the same woman who
according to legend is said to have
given Excalibur to Arthur in the first
place perhaps Excalibur will be used to
somehow seal away the demon king for
good maybe even inside of Excalibur
itself but we will have to wait and find
out
the other big lingering question and it
has been lingering for a long long time
is whether the supreme deity will ever
make an actual appearance is she going
to become involved in this battle is she
going to be part of some future battle
or is she going to remain off-screen for
the rest of the story or maybe she will
show up after this battle and say
something like hey thanks for defeating
the demon king guys very cool I honestly
have no idea but I'm itching to find out
more about the supreme deity especially
after the whole bloody ellie reveal and
the sudden surge in Elizabeth's strength
let me know what you guys think will
this be the most epic battle in the
seven deadly sins so far or do you
expect that the sins and Elisabeth will
succeed in taking out the demon king
without too much trouble and do you
think that we are ever going to see
Arthur and the supreme deity again if so
what role will they actually play let me
know down in the comments if you enjoyed
the seven deadly sins content on this
channel and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime outpour
for all the latest seven deadly sins
news and updates and don't forget to
check out our sponsor crunchyroll link
in the description as always thank you
guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it and until next time see
our space cowboys
[Music]